hola bueno pues hoy veamos si podemos
aprender un par de cosas acerca de la
hipérbola y bueno fuera de toda esta
sección de cónicas que hemos visto
anteriormente esta es la que quizás
confunde un poco más a la gente porque
no es tan fácil de dibujarla como la
circunferencia y las elipses pues tienes
que realizar un poco más de álgebra pero
con optimismo creo que en el transcurso
del vídeo lograremos estar conformes con
esto y bueno verás las hipérboles de una
manera más divertida que espero y hasta
te gusten más que otras cónicas así que
primero empecemos con un pequeño repaso
visualicemos un tanto las ecuaciones
estandarizadas de cónicas anteriores que
hemos visualizado entonces aquí tenemos
la ecuación estandarizada de una de un
círculo y que es x cuadrada más de
cuadrada igual r cuadrada y veamos que
esto es lo mismo que si dividimos por
ambas partes de la ecuación sobre r
cuadrada lo cual nos va a servir para
visualizar de otra forma dicha ecuación
y llegar a lo
a lo siguiente si x cuadrada sobre re
cuadrada más cuadradas sobre la re
cuadrada igual a 1 y esto es un círculo
pero bien no perdamos de vista que estos
son un repaso para entender lo próximo y
bueno en cuanto al círculo sabemos que
todos sus puntos son equidistantes lo
que nos quiere decir que tiene un eje
mayor y un eje menor con la misma
distancia lo cual no hace ninguna
distinción entre estos dos pues tiene
siempre la misma distancia del punto al
centro y esto fue en cuanto al círculo
ahora vamos en cuanto a la elipse pues
fue mucho más bonita cuando la estuvimos
estudiando pues para los dos o las dos
constantes que nos aparecen en el
numerador éstas podrían ser diferentes
pues la distancia al centro podía
cambiar por lo que nos queda x cuadrada
sobre a cuadrada malla cuadrada sobre el
cuadrado igual a 1 y esta es la elipse
ahora me gustaría omitir la la parábola
por un momento pues la parábola es como
un caso muy interesante que me gustaría
retomar en próximos vídeos muy
profundamente pero
la hipérbola es muy cercana a esta
fórmula y existen dos formas en cómo la
hipérbola puede ser representada vamos a
ver la primera que sería esta notemos
que la única diferencia entre esta otra
ecuación y esta de aquí es que en lugar
de un más hay un menos afectándola y
encuadrada por aquí así que esto podría
ser la primera representación de la
hipérbola y la otra forma en cómo
podríamos ver es que el signo está
afectando pero a la equis cuadrada por
lo tanto nos quedaría cuadrada sobre b
cuadrada menos equis cuadrada sobre a
cuadrada igual a 1 entonces a la primera
afecta a las de cuadradas y esta segunda
afecta a nuestra parte de las equis y
bueno ahora quiero que veamos cómo
podríamos graficar o visualizar las
gráficas de este par de parábolas y
claro que podríamos hacer los dos casos
pues aparecen en un buen de libros de
texto o incluso si buscas en internet en
la web los podrías encontrar pero a
veces simplemente dan las fórmulas pero
la verdad es que a mí no me gusta
solamente dar fórmulas porque siempre
olvido y tú terminas olvidaría de
inmediato después de un examen express
aunque quizás las quieras memorizar
simplemente para estar listo en dicho
examen mente servía de nada pues las
olvidarías y la hace el segundo caso por
lo que no me gusta aprenderme las de
memoria es que probablemente te podrías
confundir algunas veces si te dado unas
constantes diferentes abajo porque
podrían llamarlas al cuadrada y be
cuadrada o con cualquier otro término
pues simplemente es notación ya que
aparte de todo éstas nos sirven para ver
cuáles son las as in total de nuestras
hipérbola sí probablemente si te
confundes con dicha anotación podrías
estar las calculando mal y bueno
calculando en mensajes into estás para
nuestra primera ecuación cuando el menos
afecta alayes restamos de ambas partes x
cuadradas sobre a cuadrada y nos queda
este término y después como nos interesa
a despejar b pues vamos a multiplicar
ambos lados de la ecuación por menos b
cuadrada y este término nos lo cambia al
menos de cuadrada a simplemente tener ye
cuadrada esto es igual a menos
de cuadrada este menos con el menos debe
cuadrada se vuelve uno más b cuadrada
sobre a cuadrada por todo esto por equis
cuadrada y prometo que ya casi llegamos
luego de esto ya es igual a por las
propiedades de la raíz cuadrada tenemos
que es más menos la raíz cuadrada de
cambiamos esto de aquí de orden
simplemente para tener por estética
matemática el término positivo primero
entonces es de cuadrada sobre a cuadrada
por x cuadrada menos b cuadrada y ahora
diríase y dijiste que esto ya sería más
simple y los estamos resolviendo de una
forma muy complicada pero recuerda
estamos simplemente haciendo esto para
figurar nos o visualizar perfectamente
bien las síntomas de nuestra hipérbola
solamente para darle sentido a todo lo
que estamos diciendo pero déjame hacerlo
por aquí vamos a hacerlo gráficamente
entonces dicha hipérbola tiene dos
síntomas a las cuales se va a estar
aproximando
así que serían estas dos que estamos por
aquí dibujando entonces como ya había
mencionado son las asín total a lo que
la gráfica en este pero la se va a ir
aproximando pero nunca nunca las va a
tocar y si eres observador es una la
negativa de la otra o sea con una
pendiente contraria a la que teníamos
primero y claro que no estoy dibujando
todo esto perfecto pero tampoco toca la
5ta simplemente es cada vez más cerca
arbitrariamente cercanísima a la 5ta
también luce algo como esto donde si
vemos que nuestra hipérbola abre hacia
la izquierda y a la derecha obviamente
es posible que también abra hacia arriba
y hacia abajo pero cuando estamos
hablando de nuestro otro tipo de
ecuación y conforme más y más se acerque
a la 5ta significa que cada vez estará
más cerca a estas líneas pero sin
tocarlas conseguirá estar infinitamente
cerca como también infinitamente lejos
conforme x tome valores muy grandes
entonces conforme x
tienda a más menos infinito en esta
parte que estoy aquí encerrando qué
pasaría si x toma valores muy grandes y
los sustituye y es un valor
extremadamente grande este término
constante por acá prácticamente le hace
nada a nuestro súper número que tenemos
del lado izquierdo así que podríamos
decir que ye se va a aproximar conforme
x tome valores muy pero muy grandes sea
enorme creo que este es el símbolo el
símbolo de congruente más bien quiero
buscar por acá como sería el de
aproximación que sería éste pero bueno
regresando a esto si x es demasiado
grande entonces esta función se aproxima
a ser solamente más o menos la raíz de b
cuadrada sobre a cuadrada por x cuadrada
y esto es igual a sacando la raíz
cuadrada algebraica mente del término al
que nos aproximamos que seguro puedes y
es sencillísimo nos va a quedar más
menos b sobre a por equis y lo que esto
nos está diciendo es que esencialmente
existen 2 assassins totales donde la
pendiente de una cinta será ve por ahí
multiplicada por equis y esto es en
cuanto a la positiva y en cuanto a la
negativa sería menos b por a por equis y
voy a realizar esto con un ejemplo para
hacerlo más claro pero antes las a sin
todas son como vemos aquí estas dos
líneas que tenemos ya dadas entonces
aquí sería igual a más b sobre a por
equis y por acá tendríamos la de la
pendiente negativa nuestra sin total y
igual a menos b sobre a por equis pero
bueno algo esencial y sumamente
importante también es visualizar para
dónde va a abrir la y pero la se abrirá
para arriba y para abajo o para la
izquierda y la derecha y con esto las
dos formas de poder visualizarlo es
decir bueno esta aproximación que
tenemos aquí para cuando x es demasiado
grande también podemos ver incluso que
no nuestro término de aquí de todos
modos no nos serviría de mucho porque
nos quedara una raíz negativa y nosotros
no estamos trabajando con números
imaginarios y no nos está diciendo nada
nuestra gráfica pero como en este caso
estamos restando de un poquito en cuanto
a la constante siempre vamos a estar un
poco por debajo del asunto especialmente
cuando estamos en el cuadrante positivo
cierto y para mí es como más fácil
visualizarlo siempre para este cuadrante
porque los otros me confunden un poco
entonces nos estaríamos aproximando
desde la parte inferior por aquí y como
sabes esto se va a ir aproximando de
esta forma a las in total y luego
conforme se va abriendo por la derecha
aquí es simétricamente para la izquierda
lo mismo para la izquierda y otra forma
de realizarlo y quizás sea un poco más
intuitiva para ti es visualizar en la
ecuación original que puede ser con
cuando hoy es igual a 0 y regresando a
la ecuación para visualizar que abre a
la izquierda ya la derecha veamos que si
x vale 0 igual nos vuelve a quedar un
término negativo dentro de la raíz y lo
mismo no estamos trabajando con
imaginarios no nos da ningún tipo de
información
entonces x nunca va a ser igual a 0
entonces por puro
y analizando nuestra ecuación por aquí
obviamente x nunca va a ser cero así que
ahora la pregunta sería que puede ser
igual a cero y hay que establecerlo
digamos que es igual a cero y luego
vamos a resolverlo así que en este caso
tendríamos cero igual a la raíz de b
sobre b cuadrada sobre a cuadrada por x
cuadrada menos b cuadrada luego
podríamos sacar elevar al cuadrado por
ambos lados entonces nos queda este
término por acá es igual a cero está
siendo un poco confuso porque me hace
falta espacio entonces b cuadrada sobre
a cuadrada por x cuadrada es igual a b
cuadrada y luego podríamos multiplicar
ambas partes por b cuadrada nos quedan
unos y entonces tendríamos que x
cuadrado es igual a cuadrada e igual
sacando raíz de ambos lados tendríamos
que x es igual a más menos a por lo que
el punto de por acá es a cero y de este
lado menos
pero ahora regresemos al problema
inicial tengo la sensación de que está
terminando ese el tiempo pero bueno no
tenemos que el término x cuando el
término x es positivo nuestra hipérbola
abre hacia la derecha y la izquierda y
de hecho probablemente obtengas
razonamiento intuitivo y veas que cuando
el término y es el positivo como aquí
probablemente la hipérbola vaya a abrir
hacia arriba y hacia abajo y probemos
esto a nosotros mismos así que para que
cuadradas sobre b cuadrada y agregándole
ambas partes x cuadrada sobre a cuadrada
tendríamos que ye cuadrada sobre b
cuadrada es igual a x cuadrada sobre a
cuadrada más 1 luego entonces
multiplicamos por b cuadrada ambas
partes y tenemos esta tercera expresión
finalmente sacando la raíz cuadrada de
ambos lados tenemos que es igual a más
menos la raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada
a cuadrada por equis cuadrada más be
cuadrada y bueno ya no me queda espacio
pero podemos hacer el mismo argumento
conforme a cuando x aproxima a más
infinito o menos infinito como lo
hicimos anteriormente pues no nos
afectaría cuando x es muy grande el
término constante del ave
entonces esencialmente nos queda como lo
anterior más menos b sobre a por equis y
una vez más estas dos son las mismas así
en total las cuales redibujar yo
remarcar por aquí esta línea y esta otra
línea en este caso
estamos un poco más lejanos o más
distantes de las asín totales pues
estamos sumándole un pequeño número
positivo que es la constante del ave
cuadrada entonces dichas hipérbola la
dicha hipérbola o dichas parábolas nos
va a quedar un poquito distante de
nuestras asín totas y otra forma de
pensar esto regresando a nuestra
ecuación para cuando la app hipérbola
abre hacia arriba y hacia abajo
vayamos acá arriba para analizarlo
si te das cuenta si x vale 0 se anula
todo este término y pues nos va a quedar
simplemente un punto entonces en
realidad no nos interesa para cuando es
igual a cero nos interesa para cuando ya
es igual a cero entonces sería menos x
cuadrada sobre a cuadrada igual a 1
luego multiplicando ambas partes por
menos 1 tenemos que x cuadrado de 6
igual a menos a cuadrada y como podrás
darte cuenta tenemos una raíz de algo
negativo lo cual no nos está diciendo
nada para nuestra gráfica de cualquier
forma no te confundas aún es abstracto
esto de las veces días y en los próximos
dos vídeos haré bastantes problemas
numéricos así que esto va a quedar
muchísimo más claro nos vemos